well these are completely unfounded
allegations and I'm going to fight them
all the way but you said you weren't
embarrassed file no I wasn't embarrassed
by them I was annoyed I was very angry
because when you were reputations being
attacked that's something you hold dear
to and I've been in public life for a
long time I know what is permitted but
its proper and that's what I stick to
people are worried about your position
on the committee given that you were
talking freely to a company based in
China do you totally reject that there's
any link that no no this is nonsense
what I said was we welcome as does
British government as of the Labour
Party every other party we welcome all
Chinese investment in the United Kingdom
that obeys the law and provides
employment anybody who does cyber
attacks or might be involved in
espionage that using people we don't
welcome there's no question of you
stepping down from the Commission one
issues absolutely nothing to do with the
other and on your salary and you said
yeah that was a silly remark on my part
of course I have a salary as a member of
parliament what I was actually talking
about was it might as God's my various
business interests I don't have any
salaries I just received payment for
what I do do you think I might upset
your constituents but it's all in the
register of members interests it's
everything's there so there's not there
was nothing new and there's nothing that
I said in these interviews that I
wouldn't have been prepared to say on
television indeed I offered channel for
the opportunity to actually answer their
allegations on their program and they
refused to allow me to do so at one
point that you were making was the
argument that you only offered any
information that was already in a public
demand well the channel 4 have accepted
that i have in writing from them
confirmation that i did not that i made
it clear that no one would get any
access to any privileged information
from from my activities of any guys yes
I can't I can't do to this precise
moment having the document with me but
yes I have a document from the
production company that works with
channel for saying we acknowledge that
you made it clear that you would not get
access to privileged no one will get
access to any privileged information you
did i'm breaking the rules but there is
this does open up a question about the
fact that as you say a number of MPs do
work not a number probably about 200 you
know the factors some people believe
that members of parliament should not
have any other interests well the law of
the land says they are perfectly
permitted to do so as long as it's in
the register of members
dress and roughly about 200 to say and
do you think that enough time should be
given to your role as an MP you thought
about having a lot of rings oh when I
was when I was foreign secretary that
took up ninety-five percent of my time
my parliamentary activities had to make
do with five percent I now gives 75% of
my time to my parliamentary activities
and twenty percent roughly 20-25 to
other matters so that's not a bad ratio
I'm just wanna bring a meeting Michael
Gove today what you expect to be focused
well first of all I actually asked to
see them and because I office Lee wanted
to explain what was happening from my
perspective and I look forward to a very
good discussion you said you might be
feel a bit irritated tonight when you
watch the program no I didn't say I feel
like I said I feel angry because I'm
angry when people are saying false
things okay and and just wondering it
just in terms of the actual denials of
any of the points what are you most
angry about in terms of what well first
I am really most angry at the suggestion
there is something improper about a
member of parliament being willing to
consider serving on an advisory board of
a company that says it's proposing major
investment in the United Kingdom many
many people who have served in such
advisory boards from all walks of life
including Parliament from many many
years and to produce massive headline
suggesting somehow for myself to
consider doing that is improper it's not
only foolish and silly it's it's
positively insulting why then have you
repaired it's the parliamentary service
because at the end of the dead part the
public know that if the Commissioner
looks into something and finds
everything's okay hopefully that's what
I obviously I hope will happen then that
is the best way of closing an issue
completely you didn't if anything that
you did or said in that meeting that
isn't it was in any way close to
reaching any rules well I hope not i
mean i haven't seen the transcript you
know they wouldn't let me see it i asked
channel 4's it please send me the
transcript of what I'm supposed to have
said they refused to do say so I Fred
you better ask them not me